[Music]
welcome folks to this fireside chat
we're going to talk about cloud
computing and edge computing and you
know how to get started what does it
even mean to all of us right but before
we do they just quickly get us all
introduced first of all this you know
fireside chat is done in conglomeration
of you know NASSCOM simply learn and
burn on himself all three of us working
together so if you came through NASSCOM
especially welcome to you as well
and let me quickly introduce our
panelists the main main person here
today Barnard we're not actually you
should probably introduce yourself
you're a veteran of cloud you know
everything that's going on in industry
and highly valued opinions that you
share so I'll just pass it back to you
all right thank you so much well yes as
you mentioned I've been working in cloud
a long time
I've got started with it I was I was
writing a book virtualization for
dummies and I was going to put a chapter
in there called the future of
virtualization where's it going and I
was sort of stuck like well where's it
going to go and I went to meet up and it
was kind of it was in a community center
down in Palo Alto kind of an old school
that was kind of beat-up and not very
elegant and kind of rundown
and this fear tonight was a was a guy
from Amazon and it was an enterprise
architecture meetup so I said why she
died from Amazon here talking on
enterprise architecture and he stood up
and he said I want to tell you about
this service we just launched called
Amazon Web Services and by the end of
that lecture I went that's not just the
future versus Latian that's the future
of IT and really threw myself into it
from then on and been working it for
just about a decade now and I I would
say that my my intuition has been borne
out but I would also say that my belief
is that were if I can use a baseball
metaphor we're in the second inning I
don't know what the right cricket
metaphor would be were the first verse
or something like second overs you know
it's we're still early days in what's
gonna go on with cloud computing many
introduced introduction from my side
I'm the chief product officer for simple
earn it turns out and I've left this
world behind I actually ran the product
management division for a cloud
computing company called Rackspace a few
years back and buy a still stay in touch
with cloud Bernard's expert here I'm
only going to try to see if and get the
best of his thoughts around this topic
before get started some quick
housekeeping things I do want to make
those interactive at the same time with
all the activities we have here it's
going to be impossible to have a lot of
questions come in orthogonal in all over
the place so please put your questions
in the Q&A section
I will be skimming those making sure
that questions are answered as they come
to us and as they are on point if
they're not on point I'm gonna kick them
to the end and I'm gonna ask those
questions to Bernard at the very end
okay so keep your questions come in I'll
be looking at those and making sure that
we cover those so Bernard ready to get
started I'm ready if you're ready all
right let's do this
so you know started a very simple basic
things right because the edge computing
it's a pretty relatively new term so
let's start with actually do for skating
just explaining what it's computing is
how does it differ from cloud computing
when we get started something something
pretty basic sure well um you know the
notion of edge computing is that in
contrast to cloud computing so cloud
computing is basically computing at the
end of a wire
a centralized computing environment like
Amazon Web Services like Microsoft Azure
or like a Google cloud environment and
clouded computing engine sorry it's a
little early in the morning for me still
anyway they're all centralized the
notion with edge computing is that you
would migrate to some amount of
computing out to a place where something
is going on and some people sort of go
well we've had that before we called it
pcs or we called it you know whatever
you might call but this little bit
different in that I I think it's a
little different most people mean
something different in that it's not a
generalized computing capability like a
computer is it's more of a specialized
device typically or it's it's computing
associated with some kind of a device
that is is appropriately smart so kind
of an example might be you've got some
sort of machine tool running and you
want to make sure it stays within
tolerance and if something some failure
condition happens you want to be able to
respond to it immediately and shut it
down well you could have some amount of
computing on that device and it would be
reading these metrics and if it got to a
warning level at one of those on the
luminous metrics it would issue a
shutdown I think so that computing is
out at the edge it's not it's located on
the device as opposed to being back in a
you know centralized data center so
that's conceptually that's the sort of
thing that edge computing is it's
computing being attached to or
integrated with some sort of device and
that device can be made more effective
more efficient whatever it might be by
having that computing attached to it
gotcha
but you know someone might ask right
then how to to questions really quick
isn't possible to solve all those kind
of decisions anyway so why do you need
this edge device that's question number
one and actually I was holding up
question two after that let's start with
that so so why do we need a device
that's sitting on the edge of the
network and why would you just actually
have all the computation of power and
everything to sit on the closet cell
well at least from my perspective
there's a couple of reasons why you
might want to do that
and what is in situations or for devices
in which the latency that you would have
from communicating from that device
across the network back to the
centralized computing power and then
some information or some command being
sent back across that wire there's some
latency because it's a round-trip so
that's one reason the second is if there
really is no connectivity so you know
think of a you know a remote aide you
know a foreign aid kind of situation
they put a they're working in a remote
location in that country there's there
is no wire they can connect to that will
give them computing back to a
centralized location so they need you
know local computing although to certain
extent that just means you've got a
little mini data center at that remote
location so to me that sort of even
caught edge but it's you know I mean I
think of edges being sort of specialized
devices that's the way I think about it
as being something worthy of a different
term gotcha and and inertia laughter
yeah it makes a lot of sense so
basically what you're saying just to
make sure the audience got their summary
right in some sense you want to make
certain decisions at the edge where you
want the latency of the network that
goes all the way to the cloud or the
data center at the place where the
decision gets made so you're shortening
that time you're making decisions
quicker you know you just get better
outcomes in that sense right but you
know some people might ask how is it
sort of a subset of IOT which is another
big buzzword out there right it's are
these just devices that are talking to
each other and what's what's the
difference here and do IOT devices it's
not a bigger thing is it's computing
part of that or is completely separate
there no I think it's really sort of the
same thing with a different name on you
know it's Internet of Things and devices
or things you know it's there sort of
IOT sounds pretty cool so you say IOT
based computing sounds loans okay and so
you know it again it's
it's devices or machines or whatever you
want to call it that can operate more
efficiently or more effectively by
having computing attached to them
okay offer an example please we're going
to get there so the perfect timing
yeah well so I talked to Microsoft and
they've got a offering it's kind of a
package i OT offering and and AWS has
one as well I'm sure Google is
developing one I don't think the
important right now but so they worked
with a manufacturer that took this as
your computing and it's basically a sure
the Azure interface so from a
perspective of programming it you still
got the same API so it's just the
computing is located on to the device
and this would this device was a machine
tool and again at certain fault
conditions it wanted to be shut down
immediately because if it ran even a
little bit like a second it could run
into you know a failure condition that
could be damage to the tool obviously
don't want to have that happen so the
azure IOT was used to place some
computing power onto that device now
interestingly this was a I don't know
what you would call hybrid situation or
a distributed computing in that most of
the computing that was done around this
device was actually done in the main and
sure cloud there was a subset of the
overall computing that was done on the
device and that was placed onto a device
it was interesting it was like a
Raspberry Pi level computing power put
onto the device so it would it would
capture certain signals and oh that's a
single it's there's some danger I'm
going to issue a shutdown all the other
kind of content data would go back to
Azure and the difference was the
Raspberry Pi sky scale device that was
sitting on it on the thing could respond
within milliseconds maybe even
microseconds
whereas to go back to the centralized
computing it back and do the whole
round-trip and all of computing inside
two seconds
and you know there are certain kinds of
situations at two seconds is too long
you know so they split up the computing
so that's an example of what this edge
computing could be like brilliant by the
way just quick tangent for audience
there's a interesting question that's
come up please pull that question I'm
going to get to that the question
basically was go get started you know
what are the skill sets I need there's
actually section we're going to cover in
a few minutes of you know tools
capabilities things like at the very end
so kindly hold that question I've
captured it we will get to it for sure
right
alright so continue on use cases really
quick right you know some people might
say that edge computing is basically no
decentralizing what used to be
centralized in a cloud data center right
so are we back to a situation where you
know the clouds getting decentralized
and the clouds basically disappearing
and everything is going to be done
Dinesh devices or you think these two
Quigs lists in some form or fashion yeah
I think it they're likely to coexist
I've heard people voice well this is
just part of the Evan flow the you know
the tide coming in the tide going out of
centralized versus decentralized
computing but in the past that was
really made up of Sur general-purpose
computing being spread out to you know
to remote locations or over not suffice
locations the PC is perfect
PC was a general-purpose computer you
put it on your desk you could run a
spreadsheet you could run a game you
could run some kind of analytics
whatever a word processor whatever might
be what we're talking about here is not
a generalized computing capability being
put somewhere it's specialized like that
machine tool
it was reading signals that were
specialized to that machine tool and
responding to them so it wasn't like
somebody's gonna say well you know one
person who say oh I'm gonna do this
machine tool thing in another person say
I'm gonna write my novel on it no it was
a specialized and the the point about it
being a Raspberry Pi device is it was a
super cheap device because it had it was
special-purpose it only did one thing
and it even did a subset that it just
caught a few signals out of this machine
so you want something that's five or ten
dollars you know you
the economics wouldn't afford if you
said well I've got to attach a PC to
this machine tool so at least in my view
which
a little bit controversial is that
there's this is likely to be specialized
prices out at the edge and not a
generalized spread of computing so
perfect you said specialize but I think
of specialized devices I always think of
very specific use cases that these
devices are trying to solve right in
your experience than your exposure to
these kind of devices can you can you
maybe give us give the audience a sense
of the applications where this might be
interesting because a lot of people
actually try to architect their
architecture right and sometimes
mission-critical decisions do have to
get done in the edge could you give a
few examples of you know use case we've
seen an industry well yeah although you
know so this machine tool thing is
mission-critical you want to call that
you don't want a 70,000 or 200,000 or
half-a-million dollar device destroying
itself so that's mission critical but I
I think it's important understand that
this IOT stuff it's not all super
important life-saving you know or you
know mission-critical expensive devices
my favorite example of every IOT is the
Withings scale so it's a scale from the
company called Withings which is now
part of Nokia by the way nobody bought
it and I think it's now called a Nokia
helpers anyway it's a scale and East
analytically how much you weigh and it
will give you your body fat composition
okay that's great and of course it has
some smarts in it there's an IOT device
so it's got Wi-Fi into it and it can go
back and there's a actually centralized
application so it runs a cloud somewhere
that you know tracks keeps your history
right hey last week you weighed X this
week you a X plus 1 pound maybe they do
go out walking ok that's ok that's sort
of an X minus 4 Barnard X plus well it
depends on the person of course and it
can help so this is you just outlined
exactly what this is and why I think
it's interesting which is
another capability to this scale and the
overall application is it will it will
shoot out your days readings on your
social media so you can Twitter or
Facebook what your weight is and most
people may hear that think oh why would
I want that because the reading might be
it's X plus one not X minus four but
Penn Jillette I don't know if you free
with him he's a famous magician
he was he was a big bulky guy is fat and
his doctor said if you don't lose weight
it was a hundred pounds you're gonna die
and so what he did was he got this
withing scale and he hooked it up to all
of his social media so he'd weigh
himself and you know it would say you
lost half a pound over the last week or
whatever was he that would get sent out
and he would get reinforcements so he
built a tribe around his effort weight
alone unless well it's not easy to
discipline yourself to lose weight but
if you've got all these people who know
you're great that's fantastic news
anyway that's an IOT device now I mean I
guess you could say it's life-saving and
save his life but most people I think
it's fair to say don't do that but
that's the kind of thing that an IOT
device can be so it's it can be anywhere
from this smart machine tool that you're
protecting a hundreds of thousands of
dollars of stuff to hey everybody look
what I weigh and anything I mean it's
that I think that's one of the things
that
we don't we're in the three days of IOT
and we we don't grasp this everything's
going to be smart and they're going to
be magnificent and they're gonna be
trivial
traduction applications yeah and just
out of curiosity you know the way you're
presenting it it sounds like these
computing device can actually pack a
punch and do quite a bit do you see edge
computing I also play a role in
analytics at the at the source of the
data potentially where you know you have
some level of basic analytics done in
the edge and you do more core analytics
at the you know Hawick you're making it
sounds like that's a pretty good
application as well potentially for this
kind of setup yeah there's been some
examples that are a sort of machine
learning so you come up with a
predictive analytics and doing creating
them the algorithm the model takes a lot
of computing power a lot of data but
once you got the model all you have to
do is stream a sort of much you know
much smaller amount of data passed it
and it rate you know it categorizes it
or puts it into a rating that it says
this is outside the bound of what should
be normal that can be a relatively small
computing device and so you sort of
again see this kind of bifurcated sort
of thing and so yeah again and I don't
you call it analytics so much as using a
an analytical technique to apply against
data that's looking dislocated locally
but yeah that's a that's certainly a use
case and that's sort of just to
reinforce what I'm saying before that
sort of illustration IOT is not like a
one thing it's a it's a it's a thousand
thing a hundred thousand things you know
you've got smart thermostats you've got
a scale you've got a machine tool you've
got a car you've got I mean everything's
gonna be smart and God's here
makes a lot of sense and you talk most
specialized license so that makes a lot
of sense so so keeping in the norm of
cloud versus edge computing a little bit
and talking from a human angle right an
interesting question that actually came
up in the forum as well and I'll take
that up right now is you know if you
were to give somebody advice who's just
just getting started on this journey
right they are deciding hey I want to be
a cloud guy one of an edge computing guy
or girl right
what are the skill sets you would you
would say that they would have to pick
up on either of these what are the
common things that
to learn what do you think are the
different things that computing brings
the cloud doesn't require you is there
sort of a Venn diagram that is there and
from the skill sets you would advise
them to have well I hold the opinion and
this is a little bit controversial which
is that you know really the IOT
ecosystems
the future are going to be located or
are provided by hub box so you're going
to be using Microsoft Azure cloud or AWS
as as your computing environment your
centralized meeting bar and the IOT
stuff is gonna be sort of in way hung
off of that layer on date they've
created as you know like that ash for
example I gave it to machine tool
they've created pre bundled development
kits that you use you place it onto the
device it knows how to communicate it
had in those the program protocols it
knows and it has had a marshal all that
so basically the developer doesn't have
to know all that you know kind of down
at the very lowest level of network
protocols and stuff like that and so
that's my belief in other words I think
it's not nearly as likely that
somebody's gonna say well let me find
eight different open-source tools and
I'll tinker them together
and I'll create an IOT connectivity
thing and all that no you're gonna use
one of these and so the first thing I'd
say is learn about them and understand
them and then you know sort of choose
which of them which are the providers
you'd like to do that with and you know
because each of these operates
differently it's not like it's there
from their portable they're kind of
pretty unique to a particular provider
so choose the one and you'll have to
know some amount of how to use the cloud
piece because the Computing's is sort of
the major computers gonna be done there
you know you're gonna use Azure machines
or AWS instances are you going to use
Azure functions or are you going to use
lambda functions because
IOT and these and these functions as a
service if you wanna call that service
it's kind of like we would say here
peanut butter chocolate or peanut butter
and jelly I you know I don't know what
the right if this would be in in India
but in other words they're very
complementary technologies and so you're
gonna be using one of those so learn
about this server list capabilities of
the cloud water and then really pick up
on filed a particular iot package
operates and how it works and and what
you know what it does so you can learn
about that so sort of pick your
ecosystem and then dive into it
gosh and you know one question that many
people ask is as your AWS Google so many
choices right is there one that an edge
computing specifically if you were to
dive into it is there an early leader in
your mind or the all getting started
well as I said Google does not currently
have an offering as far as I'm aware
good but I'm not aware one both ashore
AWS I mean I wouldn't say one of them's
ahead of the other
and I'd say it's very early days for
them if cloud computing is in the second
inning or the second overs with IOT it's
sort of like the players are maybe
getting ready to come out of the
changing rooms god says oh it's very
early and there is no clear sort of yeah
that's the one gotcha and by the way to
the questions about cloud computing let
me just give it a little bit of insight
there as well
but not answer the question of really
really well if you know cloud how do you
go about going into edge computing on
cloud really you got a picture
you know provider cloud provider you got
to get the side where you want to be
right and over time you can of course
get to multiple providers but getting
familiar with their capabilities at a
bare minimum cloud compute storage you
know is it's super important and and
frankly you can either just dive in or
take a course and do it yourself right I
just want to make sure I answer the
question in its entirety because that
was also part of the question
so let's [ __ ] hey so the next next
question I have for you is let's jump
assuming the architecture and how people
might actually create a device of their
own right so let's take an application
and we want to build an edge computing
device that actually does something very
relevant like you mentioned
these examples right at a very high
level what are the pieces that interact
how does one get started on the Magma's
well um I mean typically you know you're
gonna have some sort of a hardware
device that's gonna put out a signal and
you know maybe you're creating that you
know I mean and that's the case then
you'll know it intimately but if not you
know you'll need to have a specs
what it what it puts out you know what
what data is put out what signals are
put out and so forth and then you know I
mean from a prototyping point of view
you know you might be using alligator
clips to connect to the the device
output connections or stuff like that um
although many of them are designed to
take a you know that they have they
already have a specialized computing
module that can be attached to them and
then what you're doing is loading your
program onto that specialized computing
module and you know in that case then
you know you're going to be using one of
these frameworks as either the actual
computing framework that you put onto
that device or that you connect from
your program on that device to that that
IOT package and then it takes care of
receiving the data bundling it into an
appropriate package packet for the
protocol communicating knowing how to
communicate so forth and you'll be
setting some some parameters like what's
the end point that you want to talk to
the API endpoint on the cloud side and
then you know you you're going to have a
program that that calls to that API
endpoint will get triggered that's
probably going to be a lambda or answer
functions doesn't have to be but that's
that's very common and then you're gonna
be writing that function and then it's
going to go off and do whatever it does
you know store the
data or run a program or whatever it
might be by the way a great question
that came on the forum which i think is
very relevant the question I asked you
so let's say one of the participants
want to get started wants to try their
own edge device that's connected to the
cloud does something interesting
couldn't they use their personal devices
I have an iPhone here can they actually
do something with something like that
computing power or do they actually have
to get these specialized devices to get
started oh well I mean you can protect
something on if I thought you know for
sure it's a computable it's a computing
device and there's a way to program
programs onto it so yeah it's gonna go
you know it's going to connect across
the cellular network so that would sort
of qualify a there are many many many
computing devices that use a cellular
network as their continue and you know
the primary example is many people's
cars
you know they communicate over the
cellular network but so that would be
quite viable another one if you really
want to sort of start easy and small is
Amazon sells a - IOT button I don't have
one out I've got one in my drawer here
um if you've seen any of the - buttons
or heard about them where you press a
button that is odd it will order laundry
detergent or chocolate or coffee or
whatever it might be it's that form
factor so it's a little oval device but
it's set up to be something that you can
do IOT with so it talks to the IOT
service within AWS you can connect up to
2 lambda and it basically sends a signal
it says hey in fact you said one or
three signals short signal long signal
or a combination I think and you can use
that as being kind of the very simple so
it's not a sophisticated device it's not
going to communicate a lot of data but
it will communicate a signal that you
can see that you respond to and that's a
pretty easy way to get going they're
pretty pretty inexpensive and you know
that will teach you
or give you a chance to experiment with
B I've got a dumb computing device
because there's a little bit of smarts
in it just enough to be able to send out
one of three signals and enough to
communicate across Wi-Fi to a Wi-Fi
thing
and it will communicate to that and send
it off so that's that's a good way to
get started
perfect a really dumb question I know
the answer but I'm gonna ask you anyway
because it came up before right and I
think this is a very valid question to
be honest right person who's getting
started from from the beginning right
obviously they need this infrastructure
they need to know some of the
communication protocols potentially but
in terms of programming languages coding
languages preferences that actually fit
into this cloud slash as computing arena
are their preferred languages out there
that quarters used today to actually
build these frameworks well as you might
expect Microsoft as c-sharp and the AWS
offering supports know Python Java and
they just announced support for go I
think so any of those languages and Java
is kind of a quintessential enterprise
language Python very widely used dynamic
language so those are good those are
good and note of course is used very
widely as well so any of those languages
gotcha
all right I it's not like you have to be
an expert in those languages to kind of
get going I mean there's um there's a
great website called if this then that
IFTTT that basically has all kinds of
sort of examples and connectivity and
there's another site I think it's not
coming to me right now
it basically is a place where people
share stuff that's really oriented
around IOT I'm out trying number it and
if I can't I'll see if I can find it and
then set it off to you
everybody show notes or something like
that but anyway there's resources and
you can start small and they have code
they say basically cut and paste this
code and put it into lambda so you know
with some instructions on how to do it
so you don't have to really know the
language I mean it's a jumping-off point
if you really want to do this you'll
you'll grow your skills of course but
it's not like you have to know
everything before you get started
gosh another question that came out of
the forum this one's a little deeper you
got to think of it a little litigator
the question is our Vic health service
provider is going to establish fog
servers all over the world why would
they be motivated to do something like
that where they actually create their
farms of these devices out there what
they want to do that or is it just going
to organically happen based on
industrial demand well that's a good
question and there is a I was gonna
bring it up earlier when we found about
edge there is a shift toward that of
placing some computing I don't know that
it's so much the cloud providers because
what they've done is they put out what
they were like what eight abuse calls
edge looking edge Mitchell patients and
that's a place that you can connect to
that that can receive and send a it's an
interface point it's not the centralized
computing it's just a place where they
you can it can accept stuff and then it
goes on to their network which is very
high throughput and private you don't
snot going across the internet from that
point but I know that companies like I
have to know about Equinix and they're
placing I think they call them white
clods
but they'll place one a pod which is a
small data center located say in a in a
location where Enterprise may want to
connect to them and it could be you know
that those would be a place where you
can do do that kind of long I mean
they're their business case is we're
going to build these edge locations and
by the way they have they have cross
connect capabilities to those edge
locations of the club providers but
they're a place where you can locate
some computers and if you're a user you
don't have to go build a little mini
data center they do that and you just
place your servers in there and they
have the connectivity and I was today
well podcast a few weeks ago and there's
definitely a business opportunity for
somebody to do that particularly around
containers so you know kind of a
container hotel so basically as a user
you just show up and say here's my
container
it knows how to communicate with these
devices the devices sends something it
just goes there except all the way back
to the cloud provider this container it
goes into the container the container
then jumps on an across connect and then
gets to the cloud provider very quickly
so that's very that's a very viable kind
of architecture it's it's either going
to be the cloud providers as they build
out or today companies like Equinix are
painting parrots are pursuing that
business opportunity gotcha
final question is sort of a canned
question answers to be made and they'll
open up to the forum you know where do
you think this is all headed the edge
computing you know the early stage
that's today right if you fast forward
four or five years from now what you see
is all going and what's the what's the
new future
well you know and there are there are
people who hold the position that says
the cloud is dead it's all edge and I
disagree with that for the reasons I've
given I don't think it's we're likely to
be putting general computing out and
decentralized locations because there's
a lot of drawbacks to that you know
which pcs run into all the time you know
they don't work
you know some breaks somebody loads the
wrong program how do you keep it up to
date how do you keep it passionate we
will have lots of specialized computing
and it might over time come come to
represent the majority of computing
because again every device is going to
be smart and so there's gonna be a
tremendous amount of computing power out
in all these locations but those will be
specialized computing things like the
scale or the machine tool or an auto and
you know he won't nobody will be going
to their car and saying well I want to
run my spreadsheet in it they're gonna
be like I want to be in my car and I
wanted to respond to traffic or whatever
it might be so we'll have a huge amount
of computing out in the at the edge
it'll just be a multitude of specialized
devices and it excuse me and I believe
the generalized computing will be
located centrally into one of the cloud
providers wonderful Arvin that thought
let me open it up I know a lot of
questions have already comes to form
some of which have already gone into my
narrative and questions to Bernard if
there are any questions this is the time
please put them in your Q&A section and
we will try to answer them all right
sounds like we've covered pretty much
all the topics that wanted to be covered
here at this point of time I'll give it
back to the host and thank you all very
much for attending just remind everybody
this was done in participation with in
collaboration with mass comm so thank
you very much for attending and feel
free to send us more questions if needed
you know happy to have you to address
them as needed we're here for another
few seconds and we'll give it back to
the host Thank You Bernard
thank you for your keen insight here
well thank you again for inviting me
Anand I really enjoyed it
wonderful Bank folks until that time hi
there if you like this video subscribe
to the simply learn YouTube channel and
click here to watch similar videos
centered up and get certified click here